you're ready for some sick moves Sonny
your legs seem a little broken there you
doing okay you all right you don't sound
so good
y'alright 99999 percent impossible I
think someone has problems with
mathematics wrestling excuse me wait I
don't know what I'm doing but this is
markiplier style Wow yeah I got the good
half kill the melon who's the melon that
melon oh what a [ __ ] throw I give up
that was so bad I'm just gonna go home
and kill myself spike fall well here we
go I'm on a mega does that count I'm
going to be victorious I have turned
into a pinata all right let's try this
poon run again I'm just gonna shield
myself as my son here hope that doesn't
matter son no protect me son you're
useless to me okay one more time oh my
god okay don't into a ball throw handle
the balls be the ball
be the ball be the freaking ball all
right what's this poop I showed you you
little douche watch this now
18 plus sworn I don't think that about
ninety two point eight percent I have no
idea are raid5 if you found the secret
this is all that I was not the secrets
victory over my mom God why ninja
training excuse me pardon me scuse me
have you seen some ninjas aah
thanks teddy you're done good kid ha ha
ha ha oh yes I've got this harpoon now
to protect me I wonder if that'll work
ah
did somebody feel something a neon spike
fall here we go Boosh alright this is
cool
I didn't want to live anymore anyway all
right here let's see what we got here
okay let's give this another go
ramaa no I almost
I'll warn ya up get all the way poles
Galloway get out of my face rah rah rah
suck on that [ __ ] oh I don't think I
want to help you you look like you're
having a fun time as it is Scoob a half
OOP no Jimmy what you believe you can
fly well good for you hang on scared me
sorry sir I'll be back in a second
Thank You Timmy thank you ha you miss me
yeah douche ha ha oh you knocked over
your wife over there
and she's so beautiful by the way oh
excuse me burn me little baby no come on
give me up in the hole oh oh there we go
okay bye Timmy have fun at school
obstacle course number two well what's
obstacle II about it besides Oh kid you
all right whoa wow that was weird kid
did you feel something back there man I
feel fine all right
what's all this red stuff falling from
the sky all right whoa okay man this is
just the craziest thing ever I can't
believe how crazy this is oh man I'm
just having the time of my life
no you thought you could bounce off kind
of faith Ivan nothing jelly you don't
think that you can beat me though I
agree but everyone
our children Santos fat-ass young bottle
run that's what she said okay what are
we doing uh-huh oh hi it's just you and
me yeah all right okay we gotta go
markiplier that Ron there we go
I'm normal guy oh let's see here we got
a spike how did that come from a
[ __ ] a boost this giant ball I've
handled bigger balls than this yep there
we go that's tough right how do I turn
there we go this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
liked what you saw and you want to see
more why not subscribe to my channel
want to help the channel grow please
leave a like added to your favorites or
share with your friends on Facebook and
Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video